[Musique]
et maintenant on va se faire un pied de
nez on va faire un petit dilemme un
petit dilemme avec le dilemme du poste
avec la crise dilemme du post c'est
parti on y va alors je vous proposais
des choses vous me dites que vos choix
d'ici d'accord deux photos the voice ou
nouvelle star the voice ou nouvelle star
ce que vous pourriez faire membres d'un
jury de the voice nouvelle star il ya un
joker au japon joker allez-y pouvait
dire il ya un joker well as roanne le
k-way ok mais on continuera silva au
regard des 2 si si je préfère the voice
the voice ou es ce que vous avez dit qu
il ne serait pas content d'être dure et
dangereuse où l'avait dit à un moment je
serais pas contre pas contrôlé par un
pack ouais quoi servez vous voudriez je
trouve que c'est une belle émission
ouais c'est pas mal moi c'est vraiment y
retourner tout petit faiseux voice un
maître gims aussi veuille être mal à
crime ce serait fort je trouve que c'est
plus pro que nouvelle star fin mai après
moi c'est bon au sommet c'est bien fait
ça peut-être revenir enfin la nouvelle
farce et c'est un autre délire c'est
autre chose mais ses certitudes
voilà c'était pas mal aussi - voilà moi
je veux quand je n'écoute chanson
anglaise donc je comprenais rien à shilo
j'aime bien la tension
booba rohff joker à la joker parce que
vous avez fait un duo de booba rohff
aussi bref je sais beroff il est énervé
que vous avez fin du doux et moi je sais
pas pourquoi je comprends pas moi je
serai prêt avec moi c'est comme battre
sur radio avec michel mr matthieu
delormeau et énervé que je fasse un
deuxième appareil pour vous c'est parce
que vous n mais vous traîner ensemble
n'ont pas dû choisir adultes et non mais
vous vous aimez bien les deux jokers
jeune des deux attention il y aura pas d
joker à chaque fois oui oui bon alors
c'est fini j'ai fini à plus de joker
alessandra sublet ou karine le marchand
alessandra sublet je sais vous là qui
fait j'aime bien les votes des liens
même et à dégage quelque chose de bien
positif aurait les charpentes comme ça
un jour sur vision celle vie elle est
allée par allée aussi j'aime bien moi je
voudrais bas on peut organiser un rendez
vous je me réfère sinon mais l'amitié ça
existe attention nous avons l'amitié ça
existe même si je suis ami avec benhaim
ça fait des années
ça fait déjà dire qu'elle se mettre tout
nu dans ma loge il ne se passe rien
attention jul au gras durs gras dur un
bain d'accord radio jason denys je
préfère gras dur c'est quand on sait
très bien les deux vous avez collaboré
clé deux bons potes break gras durs ou
lembras d'ailleurs et on envoie jul
aussi que l'objectif dé moore et
naulleau ou ardisson et baffie nordistes
ont eu beau fils cent fois enfin je le
sentais comme ça sans foi ou sur eric
naulleau est très sympathique à j'ai
rencontré une fois mais je préférerais
de l'accord marseille ou paris
est ce que vous êtes né à paris et vous
vivez vous l'avez vécu à marseille ouais
j'ai grandi avec la ville tu parles le
foot les deux je le fous dans la merde
après ces deux cadres différents le foot
j'ai grandi avec l'om parce qu'ils ont
gagné la coupe directe tout ça c'est
incroyable ce que paris fait maintenant
je suis de la capitale franchement
j'aime les 2 200 questions d'humeurs
adaptation à vendredi tout est permis ou
tp mpt pas obligé de dire tmp est pas
obligé mais je te conseille quand même
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non dit la vérité quand j'étais là-bas
j'ai regardé tous les jours - l'ipod
tout ça on est tous ensemble je les
embrasse tous parce qu'elle est sûre
femmes regardent et est bon les embrasse
fort à tous c'est vrai qu'on les envoie
serait fort et on se sent pas très bien
ton amour sans que tu dis pas ça parce
que je suis à 2000% n'est pas parce que
je suis ton mon pote je les aime tous
m'ont essayer tous même s'il y en a qui
sont fous ils ont leur folie a le même
geste ça se voit que tu les vois pas
tous les jours et voit donc tu bois tu
es pmp match et quoi je vais plus de
[ __ ] dans la merde quand tu te dis tpm
plus j'arrête ça
[Applaudissements]